después del horror una nueva prueba para
los residentes de butch a montones de
bolsas con cuerpos frente a la morgue
esperan identificación para los
familiares puede ser el final de un
largo viaje nadie a kovalenko encontró
los restos de su hija ella había ido a
buscar agua para llevar a casa cuando
murió en un bombardeo
austria lento busca blake
tranquila se acabó
como funcionaria electa me caí lin a
ayuda a las familias en duelo pero
también conoce de primera mano el dolor
de perder a un ser querido después de
que su marido muriera luchando en el
donbass my name now estoy out mi
objetivo ahora es ayudar a cada familia
a encontrar a todos sus parientes y como
ayuntamiento de lucha es muy importante
para nosotros enterrar a todos de forma
adecuada por fin el propio rey
tania ha estado buscando el cuerpo de su
esposo durante las últimas dos semanas
todo lo que sabe es que podría estar en
lucha o en una morgue en un pueblo
cercano y
lo más terrible de mi vida es que mi
esposo ni amado se ha ido no sé que
podría ser peor buscar entre los
cadáveres ya no me asusta en comparación
con la tragedia en mi vida hasta la
música
solo en muchas cientos de personas
fueron asesinadas y torturadas por los
rusos según funcionarios ucranianos el
número de víctimas podría llegar a ser
mucho mayor en todo el país cerca de
mariupol recientemente se descubrieron
dos fosas comunes como esta